I want to start today with something that
is really important and really worth doing,
but I also need to be careful because I know
the email.
Yeah,
I'm going to get after we do this story, emails
sing, David, how dare you perpetuate anti
white racism on your program.
What you're doing is only okay because it's
about white people.
If you did the same segment about black people,
it would be so inappropriate, but racism for
some reason because of the left is acceptable
against whites, but not against anybody else.
No, that is not what this is about.
Last week I pointed out, according to a New
York times poll, that among uneducated white
voters, Donald Trump has a massive lead, but
he loses educated white voters.
He loses Hispanic voters, he loses black voters,
he loses biracial voters, native American
voters, whatever the numbers came from a New
York times poll, and they're very interesting.
Trump crushing Biden, Sanders and Warren among
white voters with no college education but
losing among white voters with college, losing
among black voters, losing among Hispanic
voters and others.
The reason that we are separating educated
white voters and uneducated white voters is
because all of the other groups are against
Donald Trump, both when they are and are not
educated, so understand that that's why the
story is done this way and it's an important
story to do and when I did the story last
week, I got all sorts of comments defending
these principled, uneducated voters.
They are good people too and they're not worthless
because they don't have a college education.
I agree.
No one is worthless period.
That is actually in line with my politics
regardless of education, but the point is,
what is it about being uneducated and white
that connects with voting for Trump?
That's a real political question.
When we discussed it last week, one person
left the comment quote, it's almost like education
opens your mind to a larger worldview.
Okay, another said, anti intellectual ism
is a major aspect of the Republican party.
They need people to be uneducated in order
to remain in power and they know it.
These are not racist comments.
Now, CNN did something interesting over the
weekend.
They interviewed six white female voters without
college degrees.
Some had voted for Obama before voting for
Trump and others had not.
But they all say we've voted for Democrats
and Republicans in our lives.
And this is really important when we consider
2020 these voters, white, uneducated voters
in swing States are going to be important
in 2020.
So check out whether these are people you
are comfortable with making decisions about
who leads our country, not because of their
race, because of what they say.
Okay.
The three women who voted Obama in 2012 and
then Trump 2016 are asked, how could you vote
for both?
How did you vote for Obama?
And then Trump why?
And take a listen to some of the answers.
Okay.
So Marianne, explain how you were able to
vote for both.
I voted for Trump because he was not a politician.
You get tired of this same old, same old from
um, Washington.
That, and I really wanted someone that would
make big changes.
President Trump, Pete said he was going to
take care of us and he was gonna make sure
we had more money.
In our paychecks and help us out because you'd
go to work, you work hard and you have nothing.
And then there's people that don't even work
that have more than I do.
So this is why education matters.
They fell for an empty talking point that
has no meaning whatsoever.
I'm not a politician, so vote for me.
That's not objectively good, right?
It was one of the ways Trump tricked people.
You may not be a politician, but you're part
of the establishment status quo that funds
politicians and perpetuates the system we
have.
And you've used everything from lying on your
taxes, uh, and uh, credit bank applications,
loan applications to hiring undocumented immigrant
labor in order to line your pockets.
You're not better because you're not a politician.
You're just bad in a different way.
If you are more educated, you're less likely
to fall for a talking point like that.
This is not about a leadism.
It's about, uh, uh, having gone through a
process where one learns ideally to think
things through for themselves, learn critical
thinking.
You weren't bad if he didn't go to college,
you're not even dumb because you didn't go
to college.
And many people are able to learn these things
outside of college.
But we're talking about tens of millions of
people here who are more likely to fall for
these empty talking points.
Let's continue.
Has your life economically, financially improved
under president Trump?
I have.
I have a lot more in my paycheck.
I do have more in my paycheck as well.
I stock portfolio is doing great in that seat.
Maybe that's why I look at the economy different.
Um, I'm not where a lot of you are financially.
I don't think, uh, I'm pretty darn low income.
Once again, I have more money in my paycheck.
This was one of the biggest ruses of the Trump
tax reform.
And unless you know how to think about it,
you get tricked.
Like some of these folks did.
The Trump tax plan included changes to the
withholding tables.
So lots of people ended up with more money
in their paycheck week to week, but a smaller
refund at the end of the year.
But what matters is what was the total tax
that you paid.
I've given this example before, if I give
you an extra hundred dollars a month in your
paycheck, but you get a refund when you file
your taxes, that's smaller.
By $1,500 you had an extra 1200 in your pocket
during the year and your paychecks, but then
you lost 1500 on your tax return.
You end up $300 behind.
Your effective tax rate has gone up, changing,
withholding to give people more money week
to week, even though in total they might end
up with less money.
Again, if you are uneducated, you're more
likely to be tricked by that.
This is not a value judgment.
Let's look at a little bit more of this.
Donald Trump was running and I said finally
another businessman and I got fired up.
Has he lived up to your expectations?
Absolutely.
I think he can.
He's doing just fine.
If he says, this is what I'm going to do at
this timeline, he does it well.
He hasn't built the wall.
That was one of his main promises.
So I mean, do you hold that promise against
him?
No, because isn't the whole wall part of getting
the money from Congress too and isn't Congress
stopping him from getting the money?
First
of all, another businessman, like what model
do we have of successful presidents having
been businessmen, we don't, this was another
issue.
I'm a good businessmen, so I'll be a good
president.
Now think that through.
Question one is, was Trump actually a good
businessman?
It doesn't know.
I mean, it's unclear when you consider the
bankruptcies, the fact that he started with
millions from his dad.
Maybe he is, maybe he isn't.
But the real question is why does being a
good business man, if that's what you are,
make you a good president.
Another person who fell for true bottom of
the barrel, meaningless talking points.
And then of course she phrased it, she praises
Trump for doing what he says he would do.
She gets an example of something he promised
and didn't do the wall.
Well then the fault is somebody else's.
So this sadly is much more common than we
would hope in American politics.
Now I'm sure these are nice women.
I don't think anyone is a worse person because
they aren't educated, but there is no question
that certain types of base political arguments
work better are more effective on less educated
people.
And that's what we're seeing here.
Why do I want to teach critical thinking starting
in middle school?
Why should we teach civics and philosophy
and epistemology?
Because if you get that type of thinking ingrained
in people at an early age, a lot of these
bamboozle are politicians who count on impossible
promises that a more sophisticated person
would never fall for.
They never get themselves elected.
And it's really important to understand also
that not everybody who voted for Trump has
been tricked.
There are people who voted for Trump because
they knew what it was that he was going to
do and it was good for them and they got it.
Okay.
So it's really important to understand that
this is only one part of Donald Trump's or
electorate, but it was an important part.
And when you look at the numbers, these are
the folks that are overwhelmingly with Trump.
This is important stuff.
This is important stuff that relates to education.
It relates to media, it relates to issues.
It relates to empathy.
I mean there's so many things that relate
to people falling for talking points in the
way that these women have.
That's why it's important to discuss and we're
going to keep talking about it for sure.